I'm going to read something Riley wrote
a letter to my mama
thank you for being my mother in this
life I am eternally grateful to have
spent 33 years with you
I'm certain I chose the best mother for
me in this world and I knew that as far
back as I can remember you
I remember everything
I remember you giving me baths as a baby
I remember you driving me in my car seat
listening to Aretha Franklin
I remember the way you would cuddle me
and when I'd come into your bed at night
and the way you smelled
I remember you taking me for ice cream
after school in Florida
I remember you singing me and my brother
lullabies at night and how you'd lay
with us until we fell asleep
I remember how every time you'd leave
town you'd bring me a new tea set from
Cracker Barrel
I remember all the notes you'd leave in
My Lunchbox every day
I remember the feeling I'd get when I'd
see you picking me up from school
the way your hand felt on my forehead
I remember how it felt to be loved by
the most loving mother I've ever known
I remember how safe it felt to be in
your arms
I remember that feeling as a child and I
remember it two weeks ago on your couch
thank you for showing me that love is
the only thing that matters in this life
I hope I can love my daughter the way
you loved me
the way you loved my brother my sisters
thank you for giving me strength my
heart my empathy my courage my sense of
humor my manners my temper my wildness
my tenacity
I'm a product of your heart
my sisters are a product of your heart
my brother is a product of your heart
we are you you are us my eternal love
I hope you finally know how Loved You
Were Here
thank you for trying so hard for us
if I didn't tell you every day thank you
foreign